hello everyone and morning
and today we're gonna talk uh about
representation learning and see how it
works and
what's the representation learning i
will try to cover
the area and give you an idea
what the concept and why we are doing it
and i will cover
literature's
ideas
in this field
let's go and start by
definition
uh as you might know the word
is
a complex structure of the facts
like objects they are integra also
interacting with each other as an agent
machine or your ai system
you should understand these interactions
and objects
maybe because the sensors are limited or
the word is more complex
than what you can
think
so we're trying to understand just the
general concepts in
one
integrated
space i would say
or if i'm gonna say it's in programming
languages
really small numbers
as much as we can
a smaller space
so let's say we have like some pictures
as our input data we're going to
understand uh
what's the main
concept of this image in the
uh
word
and as an agent when we are learning
that concept here
uh
is
more
clear than this complex
image and when you
when you when you will understand how
the image is in the real world then you
can come back and
ask answer your question that you had
before for example you wanted to know
what's objects in this image
this process that i
just
briefly
talked about is the
representation learning and this one in
the new space is the representation of
the input
and from data over coming with something
which is more
meaningful for the inputs
network or the machine
so if i will go through it by the
pre-deep learning models let's say we
had
some input images
uh and
uh what we were doing it was the
uh
feature extraction on top of these
images let's say we were finding
uh what's the gradients on the image
and then after that we were we had some
handcrafted features like where the body
is where the hand is and then the
let's say these are the small objects of
the body and then we were trying to
understand how they're interacting to
together let's say their head should be
on top of their hands and stuff and then
at the end if we could find some
interaction here we were saying
this is the human
based on the classifier lakas vm
uh i i will just like mention all the
references here in the slides and then i
will share them also with you so you can
learn more if you want to know how this
model actually works but right now in
deep learning
we are not actually
doing these things handcrafted let's say
we had an
input image there's a magic box here
we're trying to understand these
features by itself so we will feed this
one into the network and then we'll get
the
output which says uh this is human or
where the human or the person is in the
scene
right so uh supervised representation
learning is look like that you are
putting an
input let's say image and there is a
feature extractor here
and then there is a task like classifier
okay this is the supervised learning so
you have the classifier
is it cat or is it dog or what is inside
inside of this image let's say
and
if you if you could train these kind of
networks
which can classify input image
then you will come up with uh one
feature extractor as well
uh
if you just like looking at this uh
shema
maybe more wisely
so if we'll drop this one and using the
feature extractor here we can change the
classifier to something else let's say
we can use the same feature extractor
for the object detection for semantic
segmentation for visual question
answering or anything else because this
is the feature extractor that can find
the objects maybe also the relations
and the
interaction then we just need some
classifier on top of them to understand
what what is this objects and
interaction means
in a case of concepts
but the thing is when you wanted to have
the classifier here it means you need
the label as well right it's working by
by the labels
so
this is super white right when you need
a label here
so
it means your training data should has
the label and finding the label or
making some data set with the label is
expensive uh
um
maybe maybe if you want to make one
would be expensive for you right or
even if you have lots of funding it's
time consuming you should go and like
label hundreds of millions of data
or at the end you will come up with
error because humans are annotating this
data
so what we are aiming to do is just
finding one
better solution to
just skip these parts and using this
feature extractor or training this
feature extractor without the labels
right so
uh why we need unsupervised learning i
just said like if you want to have the
label uh most of the time is not
possible but if i gonna be precise on
when you are looking at the nature data
or
human
intelligence
when you have a baby or kids or even the
animals
has some
idea about gravity
without telling them or without teaching
them what the gravity is in nature
working without most of the time labels
okay you're not training people by
telling them this is gravity maybe
they're just exploring the world
or
if
i would say another reason
is right now there are
millions of posts every day in social
medias
and
or
there are lots of blog posts news out
we're creating content on internet but
they're not labeled on them so if we
want to use that data
uh so we should go for unsupervised
because the data doesn't have uh most of
the time label on the internet and like
uh
i mean scrolling when you are crawling
it without any inspiration
and the last one and not least is
answering the new questions the
classifier was just
telling us this is a cat or dog but we
need to know more okay how's the
position of that cat is like what's the
uh very easy the the loss of other
questions
so
the classifier itself engineered for the
specific type of questions
cool so uh the notation is look like
this i'm not going through formulas
today but
just for understanding uh if you are
going supervised it means you have some
labels which we are using it here we are
showing it by the y
and given your data you are
understanding what's the probability of
that uh labels
uh given that inputs but with the
unsupervised we don't have any labels so
we'll just understand how is the data
look like
out of the word
and
so it's very good right so it's like
we're just uh skipping one parameter as
an input and less polymeters is better
maybe for engineering
uh there is something else called
self-supervised representation learning
uh to just
get familiar with we we are actually
using some
pseudo tasks
let's say we are generating uh
some fake classifiers
uh which can make some fake labels or
soda labels
and in this self-supervised
representation learning that you might
see uh
later on in my presentation
you're not using the labels okay these
labels are actually
uh
generated and i will show you
how how we are generating these labels
but this this is a trick that
uh the input has some labels
but that labels are not actually
the real
real word labels by the human human
notated label i mean and in this case we
can do it low cost because it's a
machine that generate the data or i mean
the labels
and it's more scalable you can
uh
just have an inputs of millions of data
and do it
as well
and it's flexible you can change it
with the different data
and why we are
doing it i actually uh
brought you
some interesting results here this one
is from nlp and this one is from
computer vision area
and
it actually shows uh the function of uh
image net performance task and
classification
which you have the input image and you
will say what's the class of it is and
the percentage of labeled data and the
model uh
which was trained on so the red one is
the model that had the supervision on so
you had the all the labels
during the training
and the
blue one is the one without the labels
and when you were decreasing the number
of label data for the
red one
when you had one label data one class of
label data you were even just getting
like 45 percent
but
if you were doing it by the
some sort of
uh
unsupervised uh classification which was
trained generally and then it was just
uh using for the a specific label
uh we were getting like 75 which is a
really huge uh
difference
so people shown that like you can have
the model with the
unsupervised training and it could works
like in
imagenet uh very good or even in nlp
they showed that and
you you can see it right now that we're
making merging the data sets
uh and we're using the
unsupervised type of the input for
training the network in task one
let's say is question answering your
last question from the
network and then we will use that one in
another task like uh
language modeling
so when they were integrating the data
sets together
and we're training the model again you
will see that
a specific model
without the
pre-training can works very well
when when you have just like having some
bunch of unrelated data
which they are not unrelated right so
there are language still you can find a
feature of the language right how you
can
make the
sentences
regardless of the task itself
okay let's get dive in and i will
we'll show you how this one is exactly
works
so we cut some elements i will show you
here and i will use these elements later
so if we have the input x
and which we are showing it here by some
rectangle
we are putting it in some neural network
we call it representation network you
can see it has encoder inference network
with different names but all of them
are
getting the input x and coming up with
something
as a representation we are that we are
showing it with all
and
this representation is actually the
thing that we are searching for let's
say if you have an input x this
representation can have different size
it could be a smaller or larger
here we wanted to have the
smaller type of representation
just a compact representation as i
mentioned in the example
or in some cases you can have larger
how's the structure of this
representation is for example the
representation could be just a number
that when you are looking at them it's
not interpretable or the output could be
a strings that you can just see in
understand what does it mean
or it can it can have some uh
type like continuous or discrete uh or
it could be fixed or variable where is
uh this angle that you are you'll see in
the next model
and
this
encoder networks
uh has different types multi-layer
perception component transformer
recording network whatever you're
calling it it's just like get the input
and make you the representation
there is something else
that your car you call it generator or
decoder or generation networks
which
get the representation r
and
fitting it to the
generator network
will get the output
x prime so this generation network
actually mapping the representation to
the real world or output
x prime
and the network again uh could be
multi-layer perception it could be
a decon transformer or recall new
network
and
if you put these two together here
you'll come up with the auto encoder
that you might heard about
we changed the field
during the years
so the auto encoder is just the
one
model i would say which can get the
input and you'll get the output after
representing it to this space or the dc
presentation
cool
and what the auto encoder can do
we will see here so if you if you have
some
x
this one is x i will correct it later
to the representation network and then
getting one
representation
and doing it by generation you can use
it for density estimation for example
look look
let's look at uh look at this model
which is the first one like
uh
one of the first models
in 2006
which was
getting the human face and was
generating another one
with
some convolutions like two thousand one
thousand five hundred and that there is
a code layer in between which with the
uh only 30
numbers
and we call it representation so you can
do a density summation like
how the input is or you can just use it
for diamond dimension
diamond
chanality reduction
so how it works is like
you have this input you're going to
compress it right so you just like put
it
inside the model and you will get the
compass numbers less numbers
then if you're gonna decompress it you
just like put it in the generation
network
or you can generate
images
you can just like put an input image and
you will get another image or you can
denounce the input image
or
or
we can use it for representation
learning
which means
if the model is trend trained enough
and you will put one image in
you will get the
best representation best latin to space
best numbers here
that which that shows the
most important part of the input image
so
these are the objects
inside the image
and we escaped or skipped all the
other details which is not related to
the face
phase could be just these 30 numbers
instead of these input matrix
is it clear
how many of you are following me
just raise your hand
okay cool
okay let's go a step further
the autoencoder also can show
show you all the
new
variable
space or how the new variable space
works let's say
here we have the
code layer as an input
so we'll skip this encoder and we'll
just like have the decoder here so you
can just input the random numbers here
and you will see how the output is so if
we will change it
like
let's say there is an uh
numbers here one by one we are changing
the input number and we will get the
different outputs
so and we can see
all the outputs all the possible
faces all the possible input numbers in
the work
and this this model actually was showing
all the numbers a number were if that
would be some
magic box
which can shows all the face then you
can see
the
people face like all the faces all
possible faces in the world
right because the model can generate
them for you
by just like
changing
the uh representation
good
so if uh
i would go one as the further there is
something called
discriminator or
contrasty
learning or contrasted networks
which
can
tell you
if the
input image
is in the
proper
definition or if it's real or fake
let's say if you have an input face
it can tell you
if the face is in that space or not
then if it would be in data space then
it's a real
face
okay if it's not then it can tell you
it's uh it's not so
regardless of the labels
you will put different inputs and it can
tell you which input is fake or
uh real
and
if i will put these two things together
i will come up with again
or general addre adversarial networks
that you might heard about which is the
hype right
and what it what it does uh
it's just
making the representation and then you
just like use the representation for
understanding the fake or in input image
fake or real input image right
and it's actually works that you might
see uh
it can gener and uh
what's the idea in between is the
right now here
uh
aft after uh
training if you will do it correctly
then there is a generator here which is
getting that space and can generate you
the fake images okay because this this
network can understand fake or real
right so you can use it for uh
uh
for um this time and distinguishing the
fake or
real image together how you will just
like put one random number here you will
get an output then you will put the
output inside this uh discriminator the
discriminator tells you this is the fake
and you change these networks
till the
time
that the
generator can
uh
make a
fake input image which the discriminator
cannot understand this is the fake
which means the fake generated image is
actually in the
space right
and you will come up with this uh
interesting output which these are the
face but these are not the real humans
these are just generated
or these animals and
the burger here is not actually real
burger okay this one is generates
or the scene over here
you might see some noises here if you
look at the images precisely but they
are really incredible right so the
generator is actually work
and if you're looking at this uh
again over here
you cannot actually
make or learn the representation given x
okay because
the representation is an input
but if you would be like a bit wise uh
you can just a b change this model and
you will come up with
the
new model like bygan
which has one
representation network generator and
discriminator and what the discriminator
is actually do
right now
is working with the input and also the
representation and it can tell you if
the representation related to the input
or not or the input is is the represent
is the
good
if the representation is a good uh
representation of the input or the input
is the representation or they are not
related together
then you have another input here that
you can do the same
and
you can also understand the
x-given r and arguments
and you can generate the data as well
good
the buy again is actually works
and even
more interesting
so for example look at this image this
one is the
input and we ask the by again to make
another input look like this input
because we have the input here and then
we ask the generator to to make it
so we put this input inside the
representation network
we got the r we put both of them to the
discriminator and then we
we had the generator there
so
we put this in
image and uh
as ask the network to make another image
look like this image
and what what you did is
interesting because
it made another image here
which has the main
part of the input image here is a scene
with some farm and you can see the farm
and the scene
but
this one is
the auto is like a tractor but here you
will see some something else
but it's actually the same idea same
concept of the scene
uh
yeah is there or this one is also
interesting this is a pizza as an input
and you you got another pizza
it's surrounded
in the same view but maybe this is um
like vegetarian one this is another
something else right generated one
but the the uh both of them has the
same concept right this one is generated
but
with the same
uh type of concept
and
gans also can use for different things
these were and these are interesting
things which i'm gonna just share with
you that it's not just for generation
and most of the supervised tasks can
also
conduct with the
same idea
let's say we have this one this is the
grayscale image
and you want to colorize this image okay
however doing it in the
supervised uh techniques we had like the
white gray gray image and the
colored image and the colored image were
the
labels right
then here we will ask the network to
make the
label
as a color of each pixel
as now as an output
so the output is the
color per each pixel
and then we can just like make the
picture color
or you can do it
somehow different you can have an input
image
and the representation network can tell
you
uh what's the rotation of these input
images
and how the representation network
was uh is actually
really simple idea so it was trying uh
on the different
uh
rotated image
and what was the objective was
that try to predict
uh how much this image is rotated
comparing to the
zero rotation 90 degree 180 250
and then at the end the representation
represent
uh um the presenter or the network
could
tell you
if you have an input image
maybe uh
it is rotated 90 degrees
good
and these are actually still we are
called calling themselves supervised
learning
because you already have this input
this these are kind of generated right
we just generated these ones as a label
and there is a different type of
uh
applications which you can just go and
see
it can just
paint you the unpainted part of the
input image
it can drive you
to home or can do different type of
things it's not
actually
limited to the one application
i'm
using the computer vision
examples here
most of them also applies in nlp it can
use for
automation different areas so you can
just
change the input and the
output based on your
problem
so any quick question until here
just click one
so we actually haven't had that kind of
label so we were just learning them
right
so um
it wasn't actually the input label
so i will just go through and we'll come
back by the questions
if you have any
yeah if
you you can just change the application
right if you have an application that
can understand this is the fake so maybe
it can also tell you how much it changed
if you just precisely change the outputs
right if you can uh
just
modify
and define your problem correctly
there is another part of the
presentation which i really want to
cover as well
based on the time which is
contrastive learning
and it's based on different ideas
let's say we're gonna again classify the
input image the idea is if we have the
space of the input images
so
let's
use this fact which is in this space
maybe these points
these cats
are
more similar to each other and there are
far away from the the other classes like
the dog
so
let's make one model can understand the
similarity of the images instead of
using the
soda labels for example
so in this in these techniques we have
to be precise which data phones are
similar
and which ones are dissimilar
we don't have labeler if we had the
labels like if we were in the supervised
representation learning
we had the label so we were putting this
image inside the network and we were
finding the network based on the label
and if this is a cat in the training we
were just changing all the
weights over the network to make the cat
as an output
but here we don't have the labels right
so the question is how we can find the
similar and dissimilar in input data and
then train the network and then after
that the
training network can tell you
if they are similar or dissimilar
so what we are doing for this similar if
your data set is big enough
if i will go and pick two
and the data set is really good is well
normalized in the space
most probably that two random
data points are not similar
maybe some of them are but like
generally not
so for this similar we will just like
pick the random selections of the inputs
images
but what about the
similars and for similars
we can uh do something
interesting
like making
the artificial input image look like
this one
like similar to this one but not this
one
maybe from different uh
views
or multiple wheels
and how we can do it is also lots of
techniques
but let's say i can just like get this
input and crop it and resize it
in different areas this one is
still the same cat
and
most probably there are similar in the
in that domain right
or
i can just augment this one and crop it
uh rotate it just putting some noise in
but it's still the same cat right
oh that's uh
awesome right now so we have the
dissimilar and similar ones
then we'll train the network
and then
after training the network
can
tell you
uh the class which doesn't know the
class of the cat and does
but it actually can tell you
which one is
and this is one word
that which is using the same idea
uh
you have the pairs the negative first
and the similar first these ones are
similar so we have an input we will make
two artificial input image which they
are actually the same
and one random image is an input let's
say okay
then we have the representation network
where we get three representation
and
we have some optimization
or loss function right what's the loss
function do here is we will tell the
loss function
these two should be
similar to each other so they are
attracted so make some weights
which can make some
similar representation for these two
but this one
should not be related to this one
okay or this one should not relate to
this one
and then we trained all the networks
and
the last things that i'm gonna tell you
as the conclusion
which
the food is going on there are really
complex model like this one which i'm
not going through
which is in iclr 2022
from the google research it can generate
the
output image this is the input and this
is the reconstructed output
which you will just put this input
and
will ask the network
to generate you some output images which
is not actually look like this one but
from the same class
it's used the transformer you just like
make the similar points
transformer and then there is a pairs
it has some details
but what it does is
uh interesting because you can just like
put a class like one sample and it will
generate you the samples look like that
class like you can put the knight
snake and these are generated knighted
snakes from the class from from the
network
for the input class
or the different classes which these are
the samples from the
text
and
that was pretty mother v
and uh
you can find the slides here
and i would be happy to answer your
questions if you have any thanks for
attention
so
you showed us examples of
let's say
of learning on images is there a
practice to use
contrasting learning on television data
on which data
so personally haven't worked with that
data
again i will answer the same question
as
the
first one
if you could represent them
as like the inputs
and you can make the outputs i don't
know like which the task
which kind of tasks you have in that
domain
most of the time
you can use them
it's basically relates to the
distribution of the input data the
outputs how
big is the spaces but if i will just
answer you generally it works
but to be honest i haven't worked
personally
[Applause]